I think it's not necessarily also Your
Capacity to enact them right I think um
because if it was your capacity to enact
them anybody disempowered would not be
very intelligent and that's not true
that's not true they could compute it
and be like well I mean I can see that
if I were in that position I would be
able to or I can see that um these this
is a path that exists but there is
something in the way like I I can't go
there that path exists nonetheless like
I I know I can go outside right now but
all the doors are closed
so I know I could try to find a way to
open the door but eventually the cost
for me to get outside would be so high I
would effectively dissolve so there's no
point so I might as well just not do it
the the likelihood of me actually taking
that path is really low because I'm
disempowered I'm not less intelligence I
found a way I found a highly improbable
way I just don't think I should do it um
so I
think intelligence generally correlates
with your capacity to reach those goals
and there